everyone I want to thank you for your
help
all right commencing operation
generating wormhole
you want to rethink this now's the time
you wait until now they say that can you
two lovebirds save it for later same for
you and your lectures old man okay
everybody ready
here comes
[Music]
now
[Music]
phase 1 the attack is a success now
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right this is the final battle let's
go
dreg does infection has surpassed 70% I
can no longer acquire the target by
myself
we're in shale infinite
we're hand
Serena
[Music]
energy readings from the Lord of dust
it's doing something
[Music]
everyone listen up
there is only one way to defeat the Lord
of dust after running an analysis on the
phenomenon we've witnessed just now one
significant problem has come to light
the Dredd dust didn't begin their
existence as organic life therefore they
have no concept of death they began as
nano machines as long as they have no
concept of their own death they will not
cease to function this appears to be the
reason why it has been impossible to
destroy them I'm just gonna ask you
point-blank
is there really a way to beat this thing
yes but before I elaborate please listen
to this we don't have time for this [ __ ]
when this message starts I can empathize
because I'm sure you're still in the
middle of the battle but I need you to
listen to me this really will be my
message to you consider with my last
will and testament
first of all brief before I continue I
have to apologize to you we really don't
have time for this captain try hitting
it with the rail gonna get it we can't I
I let you down I spent 30 years trying
in the end I couldn't get you out of
that place please please forgive me let
me down no I remember it like it was
yesterday that day 30 years ago but the
captain got me to the wormhole above
base camp and
home but I couldn't have expected what
happened next instead of going back to
1980 I ended up in Philadelphia in 1943
in the skies above the USS Eldridge
wooden cliff section hadn't been around
that long and this was a first full
blown
portation and so i descending from the
skies became the greatest achievement at
the film
for the next several years I was a
sections little plaything but over time
I rose to the rank of researcher and
gain more influence in the section and
was supported by research was the device
that you read gave to me I quickly
became under leading scientists in my
field most of my work was simply me
recreating what I'd seen on the device
whether because I was smarter than
anyone else
I discovered absolutely nothing when I
was fine with that
or fortune
what I had done to all of you
thus the gates of hell were flung open
though my own personal hell wasn't DJ
but back here the reality for 30 years
I've sacrificed everything to prepare
all these preparations for this one
fleeting moment when you hear this the
Lord of dust will likely have already
opened a store to the past
captain it's all up to you and the
others
history the survival of mankind depends
on whether or not you can pull this off
I'm counting on you heroes without names
the future is in your hands that is good
luck final message Chris Virgil
tell me something how do we destroy this
thing there is only one way I must
become one with the Lord of dust and
review the concept of death to all dread
dust once this has happened
fire the railgun at the Lord of dust and
me Seth a human being understood death
the dread dust that infected him because
it was so dependent on the properties of
its host
when Seth's body was destroyed so was
the dust within him I will do the same
thing to the Lord of dust but Virgil if
you do that you'll I am ready for that
do you even understand what that is
at the very least I have developed my
own interpretation of it I have spent a
long time with the Karen Corps the
captain and all of you journey with you
fought alongside you I have realized
that your existence is fragile and
fleeting and while the dread dust was
eating away at me I became aware of a
concept an aversion to my existence
coming to an end this could even be
called fear existence is finite life is
precious and death is powerful captain
is my understanding correct then I think
we have a plan
this truly will be the final battle
of life the reason for death the value
of existence
I will teach these to the dust I will
teach them everything I learned having
to survive in this world with all of you
[Music]
I am ready to do this we leave the rest
of the work to you there is no more time
goodbye everyone
[Music]
I designated myself as the target you
must do the rest
I truly enjoy the time
[Music]
[Music]
you're not alone
whatever the pain we'll get through it
together
[Music]
you can do this
captain
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You captain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back to camp
let's go home
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
operational support program Vergil 89
reboot complete revealing the concept of
death to the Lord of dust was a success
however I myself survived the process
though the destructive power of the
railgun was extraordinary as you can see
it didn't destroy me it abused my body
was built with the same materials used
to construct nuclear blast shelters
according to my analysis it was designed
this way in case of nuclear war this was
quite a surprise
also the dread dust that had infected us
has ceased functioning as a result my
personalities have merged into one so I
should be able to provide you with
firmer guidance from here on getting
home may turn out to be a long paddle
but as they say captain a journey of a
thousand miles begins with a single step
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
explain yourself according to you a
massive wormhole would appear over a
mother base during the battle with xof
forgive me it would appear I made a
miscalculation whatever it was I have to
report this to the section this isn't
the first time you've crossed the line
with your initiatives they're going to
come down on you hard I imagine better
prepare yourself fine by me
history was changed Thank You heroes
without names and thank you captain
but this isn't the end
now it's my turn to fight I will get you
all out of that place and then then I
continue to keep watch to ensure that
technology run amok cannot destroy the
world again
[Music]
this time you will build a better future
you